modern warfare 2 gets an official
release date and battlefield's hazard
zone is winding down
activision has revealed the release date
of call of duty modern warfare 2 in a
new trailer and the sequel is coming on
october 28 2022 the trailer debuted the
date in an unusual fashion showing
pieces of character art on tanker ships
and shipping containers all building to
the image of the fan favorite character
ghost when all the pieces came together
the trailer also teased appearances by
captain john price john soap mctavish
kyle gaz garrick and a new character
mexican special forces colonel alejandro
vargas those characters all make up task
force 141 this may be setting the stage
for the rumor june reveal of modern
warfare 2 likely to take part in one or
more of the not e3 presentations
activision has traditionally shown off
pieces of its games at the playstation
or xbox showcases but this year there's
also summer games fest live as a
potential home for the reveal and now
you have two choices you can either like
this video right now or you can 1v1 me
on the equivalent of rust when this game
drops your choice let me know in the
comments and in other shooter news dice
has announced that support for
battlefield 2042's escape from tarkov
inspired mode hazard zone is winding
down but to be clear hazard zone will
still be playable and the team will
address critical errors and odd
behaviors should they appear in the
future however the mode won't receive
any new content this news comes as dice
outlined what the team has learned since
battlefield 2042's rocky launch and what
the teams are currently focusing on
ahead of the launch of season 1 set to
release in june improvements are coming
to nearly every aspect of the game
ranging from map updates that will add
more cover to adjustments to how
specialists are portrayed some of those
changes will be to make specialists
quote feel grittier and closer to the
more serious tone that we want to come
across in our narrative while also
toning down the more immersive breaking
voice lines and ensuring future
cosmetics for specialists are quote more
grounded and military themed now moving
on to a game that isn't grounded or
military-themed apex legends following
season 13's update on may 10th a few
bugs popped up but none of them seemed
particularly serious that is until
several reports emerged claiming that
freshly killed squads were using a sort
of exploit to crash servers these
reports were confirmed when footage
emerged of twitch streamer alyssa
exploiting the glitch while live
streaming in the clip a teammate
politely points out that crashing entire
lobbies because you can't aim is in fact
cheating although the streamer doesn't
seem to care alyssa received a 10 000
minute xbox band for her trouble while
her twitch and instagram pages are still
live it appears she has deleted her
twitter account likely in response to
the backlash she received from fellow
players unfortunately the streamer in
question isn't the only one taking
advantage of the bug as more and more
reports of spike crashing incidents
emerge each day while the exploit can
only be executed on xbox series x it
affects the gaming experience of all
console players there's been no official
word from respawn entertainment
regarding the issue yet but this exploit
will likely be one of the first things
addressed in the game's next update in
the meantime playstation users can avoid
experiencing the bug by simply disabling
cross play in the game settings while
this will cause matchmaking to run a bit
slower it's a small price to pay to keep
cheaters at bay i think i asked this
before in a video but let me know if you
cheat at games be honest with me
personally i never cheat at games
because i'm just a saint
i mean there was this one time in
monopoly like the board game not the
digital version
i should really apologize for that
you